cool all right so I'm Keith Eric and I
want to talk a little bit about go
dependencies to link dependency
management and a tool that I've been
working on called go depth first of all
if I assume that most people here have
sort of been wondering about this issue
for a while because it's it's a popular
common topic of conversation but just to
like give a little bit of background
this is this is sort of that the problem
as I tend to think about it well first
of all when a lot of people talk about
go dependency management there's an
assumption that there's a problem
because a lot of people complain about
the fact that well the go tool when you
type go get it just downloads whatever
is on the tip of master branch of all
the dependencies for for the package
that you're in and just goes out and
tries to compile it with whatever's
there for for a lot of projects that's
fine if you're you know if it's a new
project if it's a hobby if you're just
getting started or even if it's a
serious production code and you're just
only using the standard library which a
surprising number of packages that I'm
involved with don't even have any
external dependencies you don't need any
other tools other than the plain go tool
I know that like from my speaking
personally maybe not so much in terms of
like total hours spent or lines of code
but but it just in terms of like the
number of projects I'm working on most
of my projects actually don't need
anything but the go tool but
occasionally you really do need
something else and that's because when
you've got other dependencies sometimes
that is a package they'll change their
their API and I'll just break or
somebody will decide they don't want to
have this project anymore
or you know it'll get a new maintainer
or something like that it's conceptually
the same project but it has a new name
now there's a new import path and this
this is a real pain when you're trying
to deploy to production and then you
know you yesterday you hit the button
and you compiled your project and then
today you hit the same button you
haven't touched anything and it doesn't
work anymore so a lot of people have
been thinking about this problem and you
know a lot of other languages have
grappled with this - there's there's a
list as long as my arm of other tools
that could address this sort of thing
but a lot of these other languages are I
mean goes go is special there's I mean
first of all the go tool itself does a
lot of the same kind of heavy lifting
just fetching stuff from the network
finding packages in your local file
system that's a lot of that stuff is is
things that things like bundler and my
engine and these other tools they they
do that because the languages that they
were developed for it don't don't
naturally have already happen towards it
to work on that stuff so in addition to
like what are the dependencies they're
also touching things over the network
etc and then plus you know what would go
with with things like go phones it's a
lot easier to do
machine translation of source code you
could rewrite parts of your you know
import pads you can you can do all kinds
of fun stuff that's a lot a lot uglier
if it's even possible in other languages
so I think the potential is there to do
better and go then then what we might
see with with these other languages and
of course a lot of people have felt the
same way there's there's literally a lot
of tons of people who've worked on this
problem for guv itself I mean I'm not
gonna list all of these out but you can
see so
you know I took a look at this and I
thought yeah this is this is great I
agree that it's a problem and you know
like a lot of there's some really good
ideas and a lot of these tools that are
out there but man this is just a mess
you know wouldn't it wouldn't it be
great if there was just like one really
good one and then everyone could use
that tool so of course so of course the
natural solution is to write another go
dependency tool which which I did I
actually so so hence the birth of go dev
in in my defense when I started working
on this there weren't as many other
tools already out there but and another
thing is that I think that I looked
around because I thought you know I I
really don't want to write this so I
don't have to but I didn't see anything
that had an approach that was even
remotely similar to what I wanted out of
a tool most of the ones that I saw were
basically clones of bundler or in that
in that vein I decided to include a
screenshot because I think my this talk
has too much text and not enough
pictures so here's a picture of some
text all right so so there's this thing
called godet and let me be very clear
about what what I wanted to do and what
I actually really don't want it to do so
the main goal of go dev is to give you
reproducible builds to let you like I
said before you hit the button to
compile your project one day you hit
that button the next day and you know
it's going to do the same thing another
goal is to actually keep the tool itself
kind of small in this sense that I don't
want you to have to learn a whole lot of
new commands and I don't want to have to
rebuild stuff that the go tool already
does if I can avoid it and along the
same lines I want to try and keep a
smooth workflow you know in your day to
day programming when you're running go
build and go test over and over
I don't want to interrupt that workflow
with a bunch of extra steps to to deal
with dependencies so keep that man to a
minimum another another small goal along
those lines is you know if you've got a
new person joining your project you've
already got code base it has all these
dependencies it's nice if it's if it's
as easy as possible for a new person to
get up to speed
goodness knows like one of the most
painful aspects of software development
it's just getting all of the like
ridiculous
you know crap loads of tools installed
on a new system just before you can even
write hello world so I'm trying to avoid
contributing to that problem and then
one more bonus goal and this is more of
like a side effect but I also maintained
that the Heroku build pack for go and
the Heroku build pack has has a little
bit of trouble with plain bear go
project depositories because it has
almost but not quite enough information
to just compile everything automatically
the main thing that it needs is it needs
to know the name of your package if
you've got multiple packages inside of a
single repo I won't go into all them
like talk to me about it later if you're
interested it's it's it's just it's this
little annoying problem and I know that
if you had a tool that's you know go Deb
is one example but basically any go
dependency tool that leaves some sort of
a manifest or a list of metadata in the
repository there's an opportunity there
for it to just include just that little
extra bit of information and as a side
effect that the Heroku build pack can be
a lot faster and a lot more seamless
anyway so anteye goals of this of this
all things that it's not just I'm not
trying to do I really don't want to do
these things I want to avoid doing that
one is I don't want to add another level
of indirection sometimes when people
talk about the problem of like if you've
got some sub package that you're using
and it gets a new maintainer and/or that
somebody like moves it to Google code or
something and now if you've got a new
import path a common reaction is oh well
you know if we could just make this
centralized repository of names and
everyone can just grab a name and then
the name would point to the real import
path and the tool would you know go and
look up in this central repo of names
where to get the code from it could
solve that problem I mean yes every
problem in computer science can be
solved by adding another level of
indirection except for the problem of
too many levels of indirection but
basically this is just and this is one
IV that really as a separate problem and
the specific problem of having them
having a project that moves to another
location you can tease that apart and
view it as a couple of smaller problems
first of all if you don't actually need
to update or or get new code from that
from that package if you've already got
a local copy of it somewhere you don't
need to do anything it's only an issue
when you want to get an update and then
suddenly you can't get updates anymore
and then you need to worry about the
what the new name is and yeah so maybe
there's a little more manual work there
but it saves you the it saves the
community the cost of running and
maintaining that centralized service so
I already talked about having a central
repo another goal another thing I really
wants to avoid is parsing version
streams I think that's just madness you
know whether whether you try and solve
it by you know just by Fiat saying like
this is the format and
one who doesn't obey this format doesn't
doesn't get supported or you have this
stuff a list of the heuristics to try
and figure out what the version string
means fortunately it's not necessary so
just don't do it and along with that
goes things like fancy constraints like
oh I I want this package and I want a
version anywhere between you know one
point two point eight and 1.2.12
anything in between those two is okay it
sounds nice but this is one of those
things where choosing what if you care
enough and if your project is important
enough to you that that you're worrying
about this problem it's worth the
attention to choose the exact version of
whichever dependencies you want and you
don't have to do it very often you're
not constantly updating your
dependencies so it's it's worth the time
to just pay attention and and figure out
what really works and what you save in
return for that is an awful lot of
complexity and the tooling and you can
have a lot more confidence in the tool
because the tool is simpler and you
really know what it does as opposed to
just running a bunch of commands and by
rote and just assuming that it's going
to do something useful okay so enough
generalizations here's here's the here's
how code F itself actually works the
first thing is just write down what the
dependencies are just make up it just
makes a list of assuming that you've
already started developing your project
and you've got it compiling and you've
got it working because you started out
with just godet or just the go tool just
go get and everything compiles into
tests and it's all working fine okay now
that it works write down what all the
dependencies are and what version and
specifically I mean which get commit ID
or mercurial commit ID goes with each
dependency and that is that's really it
that's all you strictly speaking all you
need in order to be able to recreate
that that build environment unless of
course one of those packages really
disappears and you don't have a source
PUD anymore so another principle is go
ahead and vendor all the source code
just copy all the source code into your
repository and check it in it took me a
while to sort of come around to this but
the more I've worked on good app and
used it in projects that the more I'm
really sold on this it's everything else
the mechanisms underneath get so much
simpler and again you don't have to
worry about things like the source code
just vanishing one day when you're
trying to do a new build from scratch
and it's also faster on average you know
when you're when you're on a new new
machine you just clone your your one
repo for the project that you're working
on and you type go deaf go build and it
just bills it's very nice
and the last thing is
do this dependency dependency resolution
only at the top level of the dependency
tree in other words in package main when
you're when you're really building that
the program that you're going to use
that's when you need to figure out what
all the dependencies are one way of
thinking about it is that what this tool
does it's all for the benefit of the
linker so if you're maintaining a
library you don't need to specify the
dependencies of your library does really
you along with those dependencies are
just dependencies of someone else's main
package and they're the ones are going
to be worrying about exactly what
version of which dependency you use so
as a library maintainer you basically do
nothing and all of the work happens at
the top level of the dependency tree and
yeah and so and then when it comes time
to actually like do something like run
tests or build your project leverage the
go tool as much as possible in fact just
run the go tool but give it a modify go
past where we've got all of these all
dependency code already set up and
that's that's how it works okay so let's
let's let's take a look at an example
here one or two commands to show you
like a typical like session of what it
might be like to use go dev in a in a
pod in your project this is definitely
not completely or anything like that but
as an example I've taken HK which is a
new command line interface for Heroku
that those guys are working on and so
let's say that I'm an HK developer and I
just copy I just cloned this repo and I
want to I want to start using it so if I
weren't using good app I just typed
something like go test to run tests and
all in all the packages but it doesn't
work because I don't have
salt as you can see there's a bunch of
stuff that's missing now I could type go
get da da da da and it would go out and
fetch code for all of those things but
again I want to in this case I want to
really make sure that I'm using their my
version of everything
and since HK already uses godet what
I'll do instead is all type godet go
tests and it just runs so one of the
nice things about this is that the
mechanism for this piece of code F is is
very simple in fact there's just a
handful of commands and one of those
commands ago the go sub command of go
deaf all it does is it sets up the go
path it takes your existing go path and
it adds a little bit to it and then it
just runs a go tool in fact I can type
go down path to see what what it would
do this is the this is the extra stuff
it's in this directory for HK and when I
do go deaf go it's exactly equivalent to
almost exactly the quit lines here
for this it really just takes that the
output of that command taxes on the
beginning of your go path and runs it
the the main difference between what I
just typed and go DUP itself is other
than it's more convenient the other way
is that it does a couple of extra checks
to make sure that you've actually
accounted for all the dependencies and
the code is actually there if you just
ran this blindly it could mean that it
was out of sync and you wouldn't get
what you were expecting go to there's a
little bit more work to make sure that
you're actually getting the right thing
okay I just want to do one more thing
and that is to show an example of what
happens if I want to add a new
dependency to this project let's say oh
actually before that okay so so this is
great you can type go Deb go test and go
Deb go install etc if that's a little
bit annoying especially when you're
doing lots of commands so there's
another command the Deborah store that
just goes through the list of
dependencies that's that's in that file
in your project and go through to each
one and check out the version that's
been listed and this is slow because
it's downloading a whole bunch of stuff
but basically the idea here is once
you've run this now you've got all the
all the right versions of everything in
your real go path and then you can just
run the go tool directly you just have
to remember that if you go ahead and
change something outside you know you if
you happen to go get a new version of
something
or if you've typed go restore in another
project somewhere just mentally keep
track of that
yeah well this is taking a while so I'll
just I'll just skip that the other the
only other thing that I wanted to show
was to add a new dependency or it it's
mostly just when you're adding a new
dependency you just add it like you
normally would you put a new line in
this in the source code you can make
sure everything compiles properly and
when you're ready to check it in you
type go dev to save and then it'll just
rerecord the list of all the
dependencies in the same place that it
normally is which is actually I should
show this there's a directory called
code EPS and inside of there is a JSON
file and it just has a list of all the
dependencies and the version of each one
and a couple of other tiny things in
there okay so that's how that works so
what's left to do
first of all go dip is ready to use
right now it works great people are
using it on a number of projects in
production and it's safe to be a bunch
of work and it's I think safe some of my
co-workers a bunch of work but there's
still a couple of things left to do one
is to generalize it it for the most part
assuming that you're using the standard
go workspace for our you know the
standard convento conventions for laying
at your source code go deb doesn't
really make assumption tries not to make
assumptions beyond that about how things
are structured so it should work on just
about any go project but there's still a
couple of situations where where i've
either made a mistake there or there's
still an assumption in there
and I want to try and get rid of those
so that is it's really as generous as it
should reasonably be expected to be
there's still a few bugs of course that
need to be fixed and just one or two
features I think that really really are
obviously missing but it's very close to
what I considered completely like it
really doesn't I don't want it to be
this growing you know huge project that
continues to agglomerate more and more
functionality it's basically finished
except for the ongoing maintenance work
it shouldn't really grow so if you want
to if you want to help out that would be
of course most welcome there's the URL
up there and that's about